shot what I want you to do real quick I
just want you to turn around put your
hands run your back
okay stop
running stop running man out run all
right body cam video captures the
moments a registered sex offender tried
running from police after giving the
officer a fake name during a traffic
stop the incident happened on January
29th in Port Orange Florida a coastal
city in hour north of Orlando according
to the Port Orange Police Department a
beyond the lookout warning was issued
for a white older model Lexus an officer
located the driver at the pumps of a
7-Eleven gas station and when the
officer asked the driver his name he
decides to give a fake one real quick so
you want to say the jam is Blake Barry
Anderson henders shot Hendershot okay
that's what we're going to go with all
right I'm going to give you one chance
give me your real name all right so if
it if that is not your real name we can
avoid that one charge and we can just go
by the reason why I'm stopping you
reason why I'm getting out with you what
do we want to do um
1031 is that your is that is that your
actual name the one you just gave me
yeah the driver's name wasn't Blake his
name was sha Gary Hendershot a man who
police describe as a violent sexual
predator Hendershot had an open warrant
for failing to report his change of
residence just fav I just want you to
sit right there for me and just uh get
your hands out of your uh out of your
pocket and you have no form of
identification on you at all no sir okay
after the officer returns from his
vehicle that's when hinder shot decides
to make a run for it Barefoot and all
what I want you to do real quick I just
want you to turn around put your hands
on your back
okay
run stop running man you're not going to
out run all
right the chase was shortlived and
hinder shot was caught within seconds
get on your stomach right now get on
your
stomach
all right CRA I got him on the ground
Delon
right all right well I'm going to hand
cff you I'm move your side okay
Hendershot was cuffed and taken to jail
where he remains behind bars in the
Valia County Jail in addition to his
out-of-county warrant he was also
charged with giving a false name and
resisting arrest we're staying in the
Sunshine State but heading down south to
Miami dat County where a woman thought
chowing down on evidence would get her
out of trouble what do you what did you
put in your
mouth spit that all spit that out what
are you doing the incident happened in
November according to police they were
dispatched to a local Walmart where an
employee claimed 38-year-old Zapora
Abraham was trying to use counterfeit
bills to pay for items she reportedly
attempted to leave the store with
$850 worth of unpaid items body cam
video captures police interacting with
Abraham after she's caught I mean that's
Zapora take off the jewelry for me
please Northeast what Street Northeast
what
street you might said
2297 that's all right all right take
this
please after police asked her to remove
her jewelry to handcuff her she decides
to put $200 worth of fake bills into her
mouth store employees were stunned at
her attempt to get rid of evidence no
take off the jewelry off your wrist what
you what do you put in your
mouth spit that out spit that out what
are you
doing come on
man police eventually cuff Abraham turn
put your hands behind your
back put them together like you praying
okay come on turn
around ma'am come
on come on come on come on come on come
come
on no no put your hands together like
you're praying put your hands together
like you're praying
there she was booked on felony charges
of third degree grand theft and uttering
forged bills police say it wasn't
Abraham's first run in with the law the
store's lost prevention noted she was a
previous offender highspeed chases we
got a unruly suspects I will kill that
mother me no do it stay in the I like
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything she
trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
ground law and crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
now next we're in Ohio where body cam
video captures Avon police responding to
a call for service at a local bar called
the Winking Lizard Tavern after
employees reported an off-duty cop was
showing off his firearm after having a
few drinks you could see it through his
shirt then I just watched him show it to
his friend been consuming alcohol I do
believe he's a police officer as well so
that may be an issue yeah going be issue
he's a 40 to 50 years old he went to the
men's room he's wearing a rubber duck
shirt some of the responding officers
then go inside the bar to find the
off-duty officer the employee stays
behind with another officer to explain
the situation he hasn't caused any
disturbance but he has been drinking
both okay well why don't you stay out
here with me I'll let these two officers
go in here for a minute so was he been
sitting at the bar or is he no he's been
sitting at uh table 54 which is the
second table down in our bar dining room
in the middle he's in a large button-up
shirt with rubber ducks on it it'll be
easy to spot him okay um but I noticed
it on his hip okay and when I noticed it
on his hip he was showing a picture of
of a really nice gun to his friend and
when he moved I'm a concealed carry
permit holder I can see it and then he
pulled his shirt up and I saw the bottom
of a holster has he's been served
alcohol today yes sir HEC also cashed
out his
okay I'm not 100% but it looks to be
that once inside the restaurant the
officers are able to locate the off-duty
cop in the rubber ducky shirt who is
seen coming out of the men's restroom
any in
there where's Vinnie
at
he's at table 54 with another group so
just keep your eye out so it might be
a ah
LT the officers seem to be familiar with
one another oh my gosh are you
serious said they were able to see your
firearm and you've been s some alcohol
today and they had some concerns all
right so
you have your firearm with you though LT
yes okay all right only how many
alcoholic beverage had today how many
yeah how many uh four or five four or
five yep okay so here's where the
problem lies under Ohio law it's illegal
to bring a weapon into a business where
alcohol is being consumed and according
to local reports there are exceptions to
on andof Duty Officers but that
exception goes out of the window if the
officer is drinking but instead of
potentially arresting or charging the
officer police let him go but with a
warning well you feel you're impaired
right now no you don't look like you're
impaired uh do me a favor just make sure
that you a little bit closer with
concealing your weapon causing to alarm
to everybody else out here sir okay as
your tab and post out the
manager okay sir all right why don't you
grab your parties CU I don't feel that
you're impaired so we're not going to go
that route you know and uh I'll advise
the manager and that's about it tonight
okay all right
okay thank you all right one of the
officers then speaks with the employee
again to let him know the off-duty cop
won't be a problem for them anymore he
is an officer um the the the line of
having some drinks and then being
impaired there's there's no he would
have to be over the 0 Z8 to be
considered impaired for my interaction
with him and what he said he said he's
had four drinks all day I don't think
he's under that that level so if he's
paid his bill and you guys are set he's
going to be asked to leave that sounds
good to yeah as long as it's we're all
safe that's all I care about no he he I
know him he is a he is a another officer
not from our jurisdiction um and that
you know he did admit to having an
alcoholic beverage but I'm
not feel he's he not like a danger
that's the thing is yeah if he's if he's
been stumbling if he's learn to speech
if his eyes were glassy I don't even see
any of those Clues you know just having
four drinks that he advised he had you
know over the course I don't consider
that alone to be enough so as long as
you're okay with it'll be okay all right
it's unclear if the off-duty officer
faced any punishment after the encounter
according to local station Cleveland 19
the charge for that type of felony
carrying a weapon while impaired could
range from 6 to 36 months behind bars
next we're in the Lone Star State of
Texas yeah we got him we got him
got
[Music]
St dash cam video shows police in
pursuit of a drunk driver who injured
multiple people speeding through a
popular Entertainment District the
incident happened on January 28th around
10 p.m. when police noticed a driver
pulling out of a parking lot without
headlights the driver then started
heading in the wrong direction on a
one-way Road 71 we got one fail in the
yield it's a truck it's possible 22 he's
almost hit us once he was driving the
wrong way on a
oneway uh he's refusing to get out of
the car and now he's taking off he's
going the wrong way down f
we are eastbound West 7 just struck a
curbs driving reckless speeds are about
50 traffic's
light it's going to be a gray
Silverado here still eastbound West 7th
passing State and Street watch
out he just struck a curve he almost
struck a Tesla still eastbound passing
Herald it's going be occupied two
times speeds are an
80 the driver leads police on a
high-speed chase going as fast as 80 M
an hour then surveillance video shows
the driver of the truck flying over a
curb he is on Pin Street he's going
through the bank parking lot Bank of
Texas
watch out watch
out looks like he's trying to get back
onto West
7th all right stop stop
stop all right he's wrecked out we're
over here at Bank of Texas he's on one
wheel he's going back westbound West
7 one wheel is gone he's about to bail
out I think despite losing a tire during
the chase the driver continues to flee
from police he's still on one wheel he
going westbound West coming up on
Montgomery
Plaza watch it wait wait wait stop cuz
all his shit's about to come
out we are still westbound West 7th
we're passing ston he's still on one
wheel he's got one wheel to
popped
wait he's going to hit another cve watch
wait wait wait wait stop look he just
struck another curb he is still going
we're passing
Carol
watch out you can't see just go slow bro
cuz he's going to go slow see
see there's a lot of smoke traffic's
still light speeds are at 60 passing
Curry he coming up on the uh University
intersection wait wait wait stop
stop yeah he righted out at 7th
University
we got him we got him we got him the
Chase comes to an end after the driver
crashes his vehicle once police catch up
to their suspect he's seen running from
the truck then walking along the street
before finally getting on the ground and
surrendering to authorities the driver
was later identified as 29-year-old
Andrew Gara Gara reportedly caused a
path of destruction in his wake he hit a
pole a stopped car two pedestrians and a
traffic light before coming to a
complete stop G was taken to the
hospital for his injuries before being C
parted off to jail he's charged with
evading arrest with a vehicle causing
serious bodily injury intoxication
assault with the vehicle and unlawful
restraint he remains in the tarant
county jail held on a
$95,000 bond and finally we head back
towards the east coast to gwick County
Georgia where ring camera video captures
three men pretending to be federal
agents during a home invasion ring
camera video from the December 6th
incident captures three men approaching
an apartment door they don't say a word
but immediately cover the ring camera to
avoid being detected police say once the
suspects were inside the home they zip
tied the victim and his son demanding
money for drugs the suspects also made
statements that they were federal agents
and were surveilling the victim for
months police later arrested Luis SoDo
in charge him with home invasion two
counts of kidnapping two counts of
aggravated assault two counts of false
imprisonment two counts of armed robbery
and one count of impersonating a public
official the victims were able to free
themselves after the suspects left and
called 911 police say the suspect stole
$33,000 worth of sneakers and jewelry
while the incident happened in December
Louis stto wasn't apprehended until
January 25th detectives are still
looking to find the other two suspects
involved reporting for law crime I'm
Elizabeth Milner